I'm very excited to share with you
that's over the last year I've recorded
my first original album I got to poop
out over my phone
in working on creating my first original
album we're gonna discuss a couple
topics my transition from writing video
scores soundtracks etc to writing
original music I'm going to show you
guys some of the music that I've been
working on and show you some of the
breakdowns of all the tracks and
different parts that go into a song for
the last year I have spent a lot of my
time working on creating original music
and that's been very difficult for me
because for most of my life all the
music I've written and worked on has
always been tied to a video soundtracks
scores etc our earlier videos I scored
the music for every single one I thought
I would be able to take that experience
and bring that over to making an
original work but I found that actually
it is a night and day experience when
you're working with a video the video
dictates the flow and the dynamics and
everything you were just you're just
filling in the blanks now that I've lost
that video track and I've made an
original album I realized wait a second
I've got to reinvent completely how I
approach writing music without a video
track to guide me I think to myself okay
where do you start how do you write a
song songs have so many parts how do you
put it all together after writing all
the songs after kind of completing them
all I realized that they all have one
thing in common and I feel like this
could help other musicians out there to
kind of focus in on how their music
process works maybe even make sound
writing easier for them for me
songwriting always starts with a single
musical idea you're playing guitar one
day
[Music]
and you're like wow I can maybe make a
song out of that let me play it again
maybe make it better
[Music]
that's that's nice that's spicy that's
exactly what you want to get to the
moment you've written one little thing
you're like oh that sounds great
that means you have enough to write an
entire song as I take that first part
that I wrote that I liked and I let go
of it and I take it tonight I kind of
put it in front of me like a carrot on a
stick
it's baiting me it's motivating me to
work towards it push it off into the
distance
that's my course and to get there I need
to write write these stepping stones
that get me to that course so knowing
that this will be my course someday
whenever I can write the rest of the
song I think okay well I got to start
somewhere it probably should be simple
you start just playing around
and ideally you're thinking okay well
someday I'm gonna have to get back to
that really cool part I wrote and you're
thinking like you know it's like it
doesn't have to be complicated you just
need to have it in the back of your mind
but that you will eventually get back to
that cool part that you wrote and use it
as motivation to get through the whole
song
[Music]
and so ideally after playing around and
thinking about that for a while that's
generally when you come up with what I
would call the verse of your song
[Music]
but songs need more than like two good
parts in my opinion I try and bridge the
gap I so I've taken my simple part
and I know what we're going back to you
so I need to find out one more thing to
connect the two
so simple
but I know still once again in the back
of my mind I know where I'm going and
I'm trying to get there I don't know how
yet I think I need one because this is
the hard part because songwriting is
like 80% inspiration and then 20%
engineering and I've used up all my
engineering and now I've got all these
different parts that I have to somehow
connect together and make them flow and
that's where the engineering comes in
this is where the experience of being a
musician for a few years and learning
how to play guitar and piano starts
coming in because you're like how do I
get this
to this Court
the ant emojis on the iPhone X are super
cool because it basically gives everyone
facial tracking in their pocket the
models they've designed rigged up are
just there they're excellent they're
very expressive you've decided to make a
video using these taking clips from our
favorite shows and putting them together
and we are going to back down the scenes
using an emojis and then composite them
back into the scene this isn't the most
novel concept other people have dabbled
we approach it a little bit differently
I would try and find something that kind
of references animals frequently so that
way when we actually replace a monkey or
a dog or a cat head in the scene it
starts becoming a little self
referential and actually they literally
are dogs or they literally are cats so
we have a scene from the wire so jeez
you know and then you throw a dog in
that scene and it gets really goofy I'm
going through and working on this Chris
Pratt scene here he's talking about
wiping right so obviously we got to put
the poop emoji there but here's the
thing about the poop emoji is that it's
a triangle so for most of the shots what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
just entirely block the person's head
with the emoji but because the emoji is
a triangle what happens is that Chris
Pratt's forehead protrudes on either
side of this emoji here so what I ended
up having to do I painted out his face
that's all basically tracked in I've
removed this at the top of his head
from the shot and the tracking is decent
enough it works so now that I've
established that let me go back to the
main comp and show you what's so funny
about this to get the an emoji tracked
into the shot I just tracked Chris
Pratt's tie here and that's a pretty
good tracking marker because it's
visible throughout the entire shot
except for the end when Chris Pratt goes
to like scratch his nose his hand goes
right in front of that so the tracking
suddenly tracks his hand so what happens
is that he's gone along he sniffs it
then brings his head down it's like it's
like pulling off a mask to reveal you
have no head and I just thought it was
kind of funny because it's completely
unintentional and it's not going to be
in the final video at all so that's a
sneak peek of behind this
on this whole process so I'm gonna show
guess how I've been able to take a small
song that I write on an acoustic guitar
and transfer that over to a full set up
that includes bass drums electric guitar
and everything kind of filling it out so
how do I take this
[Music]
and make it sound like this
[Laughter]
let's do it the way I always start my
songs here is by recording the original
inspiration for it whether I'm going to
play the song eventually on electric
guitar or an acoustic it doesn't matter
I spit ball so I get that first track in
there
[Music]
I got my second section in there
so now that's recorded generally I like
to go to two instruments after this
either I go to the drums first or go to
the bass first because they both play a
very similar role they both include the
low end and the rhythmic qualities of
your song because it's ultimately that
bass and snare or your actual like bass
guitar boom boom boom that like
determine the rhythm and that kind of
underneath feeling and the flow of your
song I do drums next because I think
that's going to influence the rhythm of
the song a little bit more
[Music]
I'll fix the mistakes later you do it
rough it does matter it's a keyboard it
takes all your MIDI strokes and then you
quantize them all and they snap into
place
not a real drummer but I hope here
decent right with the acoustic guitar
[Music]
all right
the groove is starting time for bass
guitar this video is finally starting to
get very tedious you ready oh yeah I
can't wait Dan emojis have limitations
the animals use have limitations look
there's some incredible motion capture
put into these phones however because of
the selection of scenes we've chosen
were hitting the limitations of what's
possible with these animo Jews they're
very expressive but don't capture
certain human subtlety that you see in
an actual performance of an actual
emotion we've been kind of bumping up it
a little against it a little bit in
certain scenes but there is one scene
that two characters kind of flirting
with each other and my oh geez are not
made for flirting unfortunately we only
just found that out now nuke those
subtle emotions and change the scenes
direction entirely we'll be right right
okay and that's fine mmm I'm gonna redo
it
because that's what you're asking for so
it's fine it's I don't think it'll be as
laborious I'm sorry Billy we're just
watching man is that hot for the first
time what mom's never hot yes we have
all the clips edited we're gonna have
the effects in them we're gonna take
them chop them up do one last task one
less quality pass to make sure
everything's good it's tight it's funny
blows
[Music]
gotta figure out a baseline for this
it's easy to do baselines because you
just listen to your drums the bassist
and the drummer kind of like look at
block eyes like yeah we got this that's
how you write a bassline
[Music]
[Applause]
something like that a base we have drums
we have a coup stick how's it sounding
[Music]
[Applause]
it's sounding pretty good it's something
very coal is sounding very rich it's
getting wider and bigger so I've also
recorded some electric guitar to kind of
double up on what the acoustics playing
here
[Music]
and that's just gonna make the guitar
even bigger now but this is mostly an
instrumental album that needs a melody
something people can listen to and latch
on to let's write a melody for this
[Music]
[Applause]
that's everything all together give your
drama to your bass you for your ku stick
your lead your melodies it's all there
and that's what creates that rich sound
that's all though that additive process
you know you start with that little
acoustic guitar lining in the pin in the
bottom there and he just keeps stacking
and building and building it's been over
a year since I started working on this
album and I think it turned out pretty
dang well I've got 11 tracks that are
all tracked and completed and they're
being mixed and mastered right now and
what's even better is that you can hear
samples from two of them right now go
check those out so if you liked it leave
a comment in this video or on the the
track itself I also wanted to be huge
thanks to Casey Edwards for mixing and
mastering all this stuff with me his
cinematic sense of songwriting and
mixing is gone a long way in making
these things sounding really cool it's
been a super big year here at quarto
digital and the same anikó channel
you've seen a huge transformation in art
content and the way we operate so this
is a last video of the year until we all
come back and get to work I just want to
say thanks for just sticking them around
guys and like watching the videos and
commenting and being involved with our
day to day lives because it's it means
means a ton for us and hope you
subscribed hope you subscribed because
this is your last chance to subscribe
total years before the years up the last
time to hang out with you on my last day
Nick it's like we're the only ones left
so we're responsible for locking it up
there anything else we got to turn off I
think that's about it right
[Music]
you